Distances in the universe are really, and truly mind boggling.
Even within our solar system,
it takes like several hours to reach the outer planets and it takes years
and years to travel enormous distances between stars.
The state of the art spacecraft today would take tens of thousands of years to
get to the star nearest to our system.
It may appear that exploring new worlds in those parts will forever be confined
to the realm of fantasy, but is it how it is to remain
cause Mo outer space
of all the planets and the solar system.
Mars is the most suitable one for exploration.
It regularly approaches our planet with the distance between us becoming
minimal,
which is slightly under 56 million kilometers light and radio waves
travel this far within a matter of three minutes,
needless to say it takes spacecraft a considerably longer time.
They have to follow complex trajectories around the system and perform gravity
boost maneuvers.
When in close proximity to planets on their way, the perseverance Mars Rover,
for example, traveled to the red planet for slightly less than seven months.
The space a Starship is expected to take considerably less to cover the same
distance, but with exact data on this being gleaned, admittedly slowly,
nothing definite can at this point be said about the duration of the planned
expedition to Mars.
Traveling to other stars is still more difficult.
Even light speed is known to equal slightly less than 300,000
kilometers per second needs over four years to reach Proxima and Toi the
closest start to us outside our system. Incidentally,
it will take the most advanced spaceship today to finish this same journey
around 40,000 years come to that.
Even this figure is rather optimistic because there is the sun's gravitational
influence to be reckoned with a spacecraft will have to accelerate the speeds
upwards of 47 kilometers per second,
which will require incredibly large amounts of fuel or else rather time
consuming. Although elaborately planned gravity boost maneuver on the way,
unfortunately, expectations of this kind of speed still border on fantasy.
The fastest spacecraft today is the Parker solar probe launched by NASA in
2018.
Its speed reached as high as 147 kilometers per second in
April, 2021. In addition,
after a number of upcoming gravity booths planned for the nearest years,
the probe will be capable of accelerating to a staggering 194
kilometers per second.
In other words, approximately 700,000 kilometers per hour,
regrettably, the probe is moving to meet the sun rather than escape from it.
And it cannot use the developed speed to exit our system most
spacecraft, however,
do not exceed a speed of a measly 11 kilometers per second.
This is quite enough to send a spaceship into orbit or even reach the moon as
forgetting as far as other objects in the solar system,
a much more potent acceleration is called for unfortunately even
today's most powerful engines would not make for a fast flight.
Speaking about inter planetary space probes exploring the outskirts of our
system. It takes them decades to reach their destinations.
The snag is that even the best modern rocket engines have a number of some major
drawbacks,
the payload mass of the rocket's body accounts for just a few percent of its
overall mass.
The specific impulse on the other hand has reached its technological limit.
If objects and the solar system can be reached by such rockets, at least theory,
traveling to stars definitely requires new ways.
It goes without saying that there are ways to boost the speed of a spaceship
with some of them appearing ridiculously incredible.
Others are actively resorted to even now to mention,
but one iron thrust is for example,
by Excel rating in electrostatic field charged particles give their ripples
to the spacecraft. Even today.
Iron thrust is performance shows to be 70 times higher than that of chemical
powered ones. This means that their use could not only boost spacecraft better,
but also allow their payload masks to be higher enough.
These thrusters are not powerful enough to take care of a spaceship lift off
from the earth yet,
but incidentally they've been used since the 1970s on satellites and
orbital stations for maneuvering and orbital adjustments.
Another approach implies a abandoning, the idea of jet propulsion completely.
Instead,
the pressure of light can be used by capturing a stream of photos emitted by
our sun.
A solar sail is capable of boosting the speed of a spacecraft to hundreds of
kilometers per second. And that almost without using any energy,
alternatively solar wind may be captured instead of light. In this case,
the sail is called an electric sail. Nevertheless,
it is impossible to lift off the face of the earth or any other planet by using
this sail. Of course,
other ways of producing a thrust may be used to enter space with a sail deployed
later on, but this doesn't take care of the following problem.
When a long dis us away from any star, this engine is quite ineffective.
The point is that the density of a stream of photo in Intella space is much
lower than an a stars and environs.
That is why it is quite hard for a spaceship like that to travel between stars.
By the same token,
the sale itself has to be made of materials that are both exceptionally tough
and light probably graph in film or other scientific conventions will help
develop these extra economical.
Although not very powerful spacecraft research in this field might produce a
photo powers Starship.
A powerful source of light could be created that would exert a force on a
gigantic parabolic mirror and a small amount of antimatter could create the
necessary beam.
This concept,
admittedly resembles something one could come across in science fiction in
today's stage of technological development mankind,
isn't capable of designing either a mirror of this kind or a powerful enough
source of light.
Another way to produce thrust is to use the power of nuclear decay as
specified in a us project, dating back to the middle of last century,
a spaceship equipped with a nuclear fusion based simple engine could reach alpha
Centuri in one ha hundred and 30 years time,
it would accelerate following a series of nuclear explosions around one kiloton
each the atomic shockwave would bounce off a solid thermal resistance shield
and easily hear the spacecraft through and doubt the Earth's atmosphere boosting
it to incredible speeds.
The major drawback for going head with this kind of spacecraft was concerns
about radioactive pollution of the launch site,
as well as difficulties in producing an elaborate Tapit.
It is no easy matter to design a shield that would withstand a series of nuclear
explosions, even though not very powerful ones. In the end,
the project on the construction of an impulse engine based on nuclear fusion was
deemed to have no chance of success and all research in the field was stopped.
However, this doesn't mean that FIS energy cannot be used for space travel.
In the most elementary project of a nuclear engine.
Hydrogen is funneled through the active zone of a nuclear reactor,
which is made of tough uranium rods.
The heat emitted in the process of nuclear decay makes the gas reach high
temperatures. After that, it is ejected from nozzles, thus propelling.
The spacecraft forward,
this kind of engine is known as solid core and excitingly.
It is possible to construct one,
even at our current stage of technological development,
besides the solid corn nuclear thermal thrust is specific impulses is at least
twice as high as that of today's chemical powered ones,
the temperature of the active zone of a solid corn nuclear thermal rocket
mustn't exceed 3000 degrees Celsius on account of the destruction hazard of the
construction elements on increasing the temperature up to as high as around
25,000 degrees Celsius.
The inner part of the reactor will crumple to turn into a cloud of red hot
radioactive magma. The efficiency of the engine, meanwhile,
will be boosted dozens of times.
This kind of engine is gas cor it may not only reach Mars as quickly as
just in a few weeks' time,
but may break away from the sounds gravitational influence.
And in theory, get as far as other Stella systems,
keeping the radioactive plasma red hot calls for complex technical solutions,
not as single kind of material is able to stop a plasma cloud as hot as tens.
Thousands of degrees Celsius only extremely powerful electromagnetic fields
of specific configurations would be capable of that.
Technology is necessary to achieve. This are being developed.
Even at this moment,
these technologies are also needed to develop a still more powerful engine,
which would be powered by Thermo nuclear energy.
Thermonuclear synthesis doesn't require heavy elements,
which are difficult to combine space.
Instead,
hydrogen is used the most widespread elements in the universe besides
much more energy is released in thermonuclear reaction than during decay of
heavy elements.
This guide of thruster is estimated to be able to boost the space after speeds
up to 10,000 times more efficiently than the engines we have today,
which means that getting to closest stars may take far less time.
Just a few decades.
The Busa drum jet is a hypothetical rocket project,
which is a modification of these fusion rockets.
It is powered by Thermo clear jet and at its front, there is a huge Ram scoop.
The Ram jet is supposed to collect hydrogen in the Interstella medium and use it
as fuel or working propelling fluid. When reaching a certain speed,
the Ram jet is supposed to collect as much gas as it uses to boost itself.
This makes the booster Ram jet pretty much or to anonymous.
Still all these engines are incapable of reaching even a 10th of the speed of
light reasonably fast. That is why at the end of last century,
the Mexican physicist Miguel Eler put forward a rather presumptuous
hypothesis. The basis of it is this.
If it is not possible to travel in space at Al speeds,
then space itself may be made to move.
According to ER's hypothesis,
by using a warp drive space could be made to contract in front of the spacecraft
and expand behind it to achieve this.
The so-called exotic matter would be needed.
This matter would have rather specific properties like negative energy
density. It may theoretically exist,
but it hasn't been experimentally discovered yet for a long time
ER's hypothesis.
Didn't used to be taken seriously first and foremost on account of the
necessity of exotic matter and a lack of experimental to confirmations in all
probability.
It would've remained unconfirmed if it were not for some hopeful news in the
past several months, firstly, the German astrophysicist,
Eric CLE developed a theory where no exotic energy is needed to create the AER
drive or the war bubble.
Instead length suggested forming it with a single wave created with a help of a
special kind of plasma referred to as a solid,
this special wave is capable of traveling large distances without losing either
its simples or shape
no exotic matters needed to create such perturbations in space.
Still the amounts of energy necessary to set the wave rolling are extremely
large. It would take annihilating dozens of Jupiter for the spacecraft to get to
Proxima the closest start of the solar system. However,
Eric land's claims that energy consumption could be reduced 30 to 60 times
and he's currently busy with the calculations.
Another piece of latest use in the field is from physicists, Alexa,
Bobrick and Gianni,
working in New York who adapted the theory of their colleague from Mexico and
dropped the idea exceeding the speed of light.
The dis to operate at sub light speeds takes care of a number of paradoxes
otherwise and counted.
And in theory allows for accelerating to extremely high speeds in the future.
Moreover calculations show that the energy needed to create the bubble
has dropped by substantial margin and equals the amount produced by violation of
one earth mass.
The scientific progress of mankind grows by the day,
what would appear to be a figment of imagination. Would've become common today.
Incredible suggestions turn into applicable prototypes and then become part of
our daily life every day. Dreams about visiting stars.
Soon more realistic shapes for all we know we will soon witness
humans settling on new planets and in the meantime,
stay with Cosmo and feel free to support our project by hitting the leg button.
Let's keep in touch.
The.